I don't think robot plumbers are coming
to take your business exactly yeah
brother I think that about most things
yeah this is why I want 20 hours of AI
think about how you asked the question
and how I changed it you said interfere
and I jumped in naturally and said
enhance you're thinking [__]
Terminator too exactly and I'm thinking
you're wasting money on your advertising
that AI can make better so you're going
super macro Fantasyland and I'm going to
I want you to make more money in 2024.
Gary I want to start with one very
simple question but I think you're the
best person in the world to answer this
question you
probably the highest Authority in the
world when it comes to branding you've
worked with the top brands in the world
Pepsi tiktok you know how these people
operate and right now consumer spending
when you look at how much money
consumers spend in their homes versus
food and beverage it's around the same
but we still don't have that Coca-cola
brand or that Nike brand in Home
Services what can you teach these people
in the room are the top people in Home
Services they got the money they got the
budget they got the operational
capability what can you teach these
folks about branding to take their
companies from a few billion in Revenue
to that household brand that's
generational that lasts for hundreds of
years like Coca-Cola Nike
uh first of all it's so nice to be with
all of you I hope everybody's super well
had a great summer hope you're enjoying
this look I think right off the bat
can't do it the same way and nor should
you there's a very big difference
between products like Coke and Nike and
fast consumable items that you're buying
600 times a year 300 times a year 50
times a year and have an average cost of
four to two hundred dollars versus what
everyone here does incredibly well so I
think in general there's enormous
amounts of difference in price point and
how often you do it and what we're
talking about on the flip side in every
B2B in every B to C of higher cost items
or luxury there's always opportunity for
brand to me what's running through my
mind is a little bit different
when I look at this industry from afar
or at times when I'm up close to it in
helping private Equity firms analyze
things or if I'm investing in firms that
are investing at a high level in this
category I think the thing that this
group in general might find interest in
is the concept of
if you're actually a sales organization
understanding the concept of brand and
content and marketing as the best sales
engine I think that there's a
misconception between sales and
marketing's relationship that I'm always
fascinated about at the highest levels
sales is so black and white effective
and so measurable that it's much more
comfortable for a lot of us in this room
marketing is very it's like love you
know it's a different emotion it's like
fandom I'm a very big Die Hard New York
Jets fan
there last night
I'm devastated right now right because
Aaron Rodgers is out for the year now
and I have been in a slobber all day
like I'm barely pulling this off I hit
up my speaking team and said can I
cancel today this is real this is real
how can that be possible that's so silly
it's football but it's very possible
because I've watched every game since I
was seven all of them it's 40 years it's
my religion I have a motion towards it
and I genuinely actually know baloney
called last night and this morning and
asked if I could not be here today and
that's not an indication to y'all or you
or ever that's how sad I was for
something as silly as a football game
but that football for me has crossed
over into a different place that's
called the brand
to me the thing that needs to be debated
here is understanding if you were to
build a brand in a B2B or b2c
environment how that is allows people to
make potentially irrational decisions
because they're making emotional
decisions that's why brand is so
interesting to me everybody people would
be fascinated why they're wearing the
clothes or jewelry that they're wearing
right now
without fully realizing how much that's
expressing the brand of who they are to
the world including facial hair hair cut
like when I look around this room I pay
attention to what people have decided to
do that do the Beards some of the Beards
that showed up here today
see you too
you know but but it's interesting that
that's a level of communication that's
telling people a little bit about
yourself we all do it different I
promise you 47 year old businessmen that
had the level of success that I have
today 25 years ago weren't wearing ball
caps and sneakers things change
expression changes and so I think for
everyone here listen I'm a Salesman
right like that's what I've been doing
my whole life but I promise you sales
DNA sales DNA Executives sales people
that disrespect marketing and branding
are leaving money on the table and that
extras me and that's exciting that
that's awesome man and uh you know I I
wanna I wanna cover a lot of big topics
and that was awesome
um I want to talk a little bit about Ai
and and what's what's coming and what's
here uh first can you talk a little bit
about the most fascinating use cases
that you've seen for AI and sales and
marketing
for sales and marketing we'll get into a
minute but like I think first of all the
thing with AI That's so interesting and
when I look around this room there's
some youngsters but there's some people
that have put some years into their
career and I'd like to make this
statement first
please don't do with AI what you did
with social media and what you did with
the internet and what you did with the
smartphone for some of the youngsters in
here there's a lot of people in here who
said they would never give up their
Blackberry for the iPhone because they
needed the buttons on the BlackBerry but
they did or even getting a cell phone in
the first place because they're beeper
and pager was more than enough and some
if someone wants to get a hold of me
they can page me and I'll call them when
I want to or not having a website or not
doing email or not setting up a Facebook
so first and foremost let's not demonize
another new technology because you read
some headline that it was going to take
your job like let our grandkids worry
about the robots killing them for us
we need to figure out how to navigate
this next generation or two so first of
all AI is enormous what is it going to
do for a lot of sales people here it's
going to take care of a lot of the
mundane work that they pay people to do
or they do themselves and it's going to
make it a lot easier for a lot of us
when we used to have to look up
information we literally had to get up
physically find the Yellow Pages
wherever we put it
grab it open it get to the page and find
it then Google came out and Yahoo came
out and search engines came out and that
became a 13 second task instead of a
four minute and 19 second task and for a
lot of us times a thousand times in a
year that adds up to time and efficiency
AI for a lot of sales people here is
going to automate emails is going to
create lists is going to do the CRM work
there's a ton of stuff that AI is going
to do
and so I think for everyone here again
here's a good question how many people
here are retiring in the next 10 years
real quick before you raise your hands
and please do if you are hold on hold on
and I don't mean you're gonna crush it
and buy a yacht I mean you're old and
you're finished
hearing two respect three good three
people let's even say seven for the rest
of us
10 years as we are still working
AI will be profound if you decide to be
an ostrich and put your head in the sand
and not worry about it instead of
spending 20 hours of your own research
time on the internet instead of headline
reading a couple things and saying it's
good bad or indifferent to not allocate
at this level who's in this room if
you're in this room you've done things
it is what it is for you not to spend 20
hours an hour here maybe on a vacation
day during the holidays five hours to to
not spend 20 hours to actually
understand what's going on in AI would
be grossly negligent professionally and
I highly encourage you to pour a beer or
a glass of wine or a cocktail or do it
this holiday season find the 20 hours
before 2024 starts to actually know what
you're talking about because I think we
can all agree with technology much like
a lot of things in life we become
headline readers
and we make our decisions based on a
couple headlines without actually
knowing what we're talking about and for
everybody here AI will be incredibly
impactful for the rest of your lives
that's awesome and I just have two more
questions please uh the second last
question I have and I want people to
start asking questions afterwards so
don't be shy
um so AI I run a tech company and one of
the most fascinating things that I've
seen is that AI has actually made
Engineers 10x faster right of course and
you've probably seen it where like you
know the iPhone you know it came out and
you know it it was like three years
before we had the cameras in the app
store right and now GPD 3.5 comes out
and then three months later we have dpd4
well because that was Hardware right
which is different than software and you
know this I've seen I've seen people who
aren't engineers
present me full apps because they've
used AI to build the entire app without
knowing how to code yep that I mean I'm
telling please please if you remember
anything we're gonna hang here you got a
concert tonight you're gonna live your
life this week you know some of your
football seasons are still alive so
you're gonna enjoy Sunday like you're
gonna live your lives
if you remember anything anything from
this talk and we're gonna do q a please
ask your specific questions I'm here for
it I'm glad I came out but if you
remember anything 20 hours of real
homework on AI it will really be
impactful of course go ahead so what I
was gonna ask it's it's basically not
only happening but it's happening at a
faster rate than other technology shifts
that we've seen in history it's
happening really fast how do you how do
you coach your employees in your
companies to be to take those 20 hours
to be on top of that change nobody here
can coach [__] if they don't know
anything about it
this is why I need your 20 hours I
consider the coach thing you don't even
know what we're talking about
it's like anything it's like when I
laugh when like 25 year olds try to tell
you about life
why don't you live it and then I'll
listen you know like so I think to coach
on you know again for the majority of
people here in the context that we're
talking in the professions that you're
in all that we're talking about with AI
is saving time
at a but at a level that is profound if
you just think about back to who I'm
really talking in this room to the last
20 years of Technology if you think
about what email has done for letter
writing and faxing if you think what you
know what all the you know all like
search has done for information instead
of the encyclopedia the library or the
Yellow Pages if you think about the
elimination of friction that websites
have done from time going to the store
and buying stuff all we're talking about
is time even if you think about farming
150 years ago 80 of us worked on a farm
and then technology came along and made
a tractor
and that saved time so we could go do
other stuff we're demonizing AI in the
headline reading all it's going to do is
make everything faster
more efficient to allow us to have more
capacity to be creative spend time with
our families make more hand-to-hand
combat stuff like it's going to free you
up and so
yeah I I think if before I worry about
them coaching their employees I need
them to understand it yeah so spend your
time learning about AI guys just go on
chat TPT and start asking questions like
how do you feel today and you'll get far
with that so just do that there's
there's you know it's funny the way you
said that I want everybody to hear this
like it really is that simple if
anybody's been through a journey of
getting into better physical health like
if you've never worked out and you
haven't eat well that first workout is a
disaster I did it at 38. like you can't
do [__] my eight push-ups were a
disaster the treadmill was a disaster
like when I think back to that workout
10 years ago I'm like my God but I had
to start there to be able to do things
up doing today if you've never ever
interacted with an AI bot your first
queries the first time you use it it's
gonna be a little clunky it's like
riding a bike you needed training wheels
the first time you tried to swim you
almost died you know like like it's just
like your first kiss was not phenomenal
I promise you you know and so same here
you've got a really really really just
start and you can't be scared of it
what's gonna happen who's gonna make fun
of you like do it in the privacy of your
own home but figure start figuring it
out that's awesome last question for me
and then I want people to start asking
questions
um well AI replace us or make us bionic
what use cases are you seeing there look
two you know I look the dinosaurs used
to rule [__]
like I never say never to anything do I
believe anybody here in their lifetime
will face a world where robots replace
us no I do not do I do I think anyone
here who has children or grandchildren
that they will face that I do not we're
too far along no matter how fast it's
moving but I don't know when I'm
chilling in heaven in 900 years I'm
gonna be happy that I didn't answer you
definitively no if because like you know
what I mean like like there's yes there
may be a time but like I we're just so
far away from that kind of sci-fi
reality at the same token I think we can
all agree a lot
I'm gonna say this nice and slow a lot
has changed in the last 25 years
technology wise socially too and lots of
things but my gosh like I I am 47 years
old I don't think of I think of myself
and at half time I got another 47 to go
I lived my entire childhood through high
school without ever being on a computer
besides school when they made me right
like I did not have the internet
my entire childhood so this is all
moving there's a lot going on so I think
the next this is why I did the 10 years
raise your hand I really desperately
when I look at a room like this this is
where I have a lot of passion when I
come and speak like what am I trying to
accomplish I'm trying to provide value
when I look around this room and I think
about all the winning that is going on
this is a successful group and I say to
myself if they don't pay attention and
understand how important and profound
this technology is that's going to leave
opportunity on the table for them and
it's going to leave opportunity for
others on the table to potentially and
so it's it just seems like a very big
missed opportunity more it's not going
to put you out of business you're not
gonna but like
kind of like when I consult on
businesses I'll push them on social
media or this or whatever the best you
know tips are of the day and you know if
I push a little too hard or if they're
like super not into what I'm saying
they're like Gary
like I get it you want me to do all this
stuff but I'm doing 16 million dollars a
year in my company and I'm like John
what's wrong with 32
and that's what the convo we're having
here right now it's not like life or
death but let there be no confusion it's
happening right now and in two years and
four and six in my world that I'm very
passionate about which is communication
five years how many people here follow
me a little bit or somewhat thank you so
and how many people here have followed
me for more than four years
so for the people that just raised their
hands you all know four or five years
ago I'm yelling screaming Tick Tock and
nobody's listening everybody who's
chilling in Instagram if at all and then
Tick Tock happens and a lot of people
regret not going hard when I yelled
about it four or five years ago not
because they're out of business but
because they left a lot of money
opportunity happens maybe a change of
career or building something around
there was just a land grab of
opportunity that's how I feel about this
AI thing a lot of people here can have
dramatically more efficient sales
organizations
you could drive down your cost by 50 and
Forex your Revenue why wouldn't you
you could keep doing it the way you're
doing look I
get trained I mean I could right like
but like or a horse they used to
prefer to take a plane and so that's
what I think is happening here like this
is about understanding how profound
these technology movements are and
understanding like the only thing
holding you back is a subjective opinion
or ideology that you're holding and I
think that's bad business strategy
that's awesome give a hand for Gary man
that was
gonna start taking questions from the
crowd if you have questions just like
come up to the mic and ask your question
so that everybody else can hear so yeah
yes do it honestly this is it I'm gonna
leave soon so like don't I know people
get timid and shy like here's the mic
get in this hi so
um I do Tick Tock for the trades and I I
know you talk a lot about AI but Tick
Tock was your thing like you just said
and I think that what happens as a
marketing company I do organic social
media and that's a lot harder to say we
got this lead directly from here every
single time but it's important when it
comes to overall branding and so I'm
just curious about like how that
how to justify them yeah how to have
that conversation I think when I look
around a room like this nine out of 10
people if you're doing just organic
social so just ground this conversation
you're posting on social content to
build awareness for your business your
brand building it's not as sales
oriented it's not performance oriented
look the reality is nine out of 10
people are going to struggle with that
because people want to measure what
they're spending money on and most
people don't think about business the
way they think about real life in real
life they may spend money on things that
aren't Roi positive that make them happy
or they know that that's good
but they can't see the direct results
immediately working out you may pour a
lot of dollars into that you're not
going to see muscles the next day or
lose 50 but you know it's right in
business there's a lot of people that
struggle with knowing building brand is
right and when something new like social
media they might buy Billboards and no
it's right even though they don't get
direct lead because that's been around
for a while and they can accept that but
making tick tocks they don't understand
that yet I'm empathetic to that there's
two ways Jen one just spend all your
time finding the one out of ten instead
of trying to convince the nine out of
ten yeah number two
you may want to look at yourself and say
hey I'm tired of justifying this maybe I
want to bring in media capabilities and
with media and creative
when you're spending money on the ads
not just the organic you can then start
showing them you got 113 leads from your
Tick Tock this month yeah because you're
running ads which gives you a much
better chance than just relying on the
organic reach that's that's the two ways
I think about your world love it thank
you so much
good thanks
what's your name on my phone thank you
thanks brother what's your name hey I'm
Jeremiah nice to meet you hey so you
know and everything you know and and I
would just say if you're down here
asking yourself a question what question
would that be
a tough question because the reality is
this one again when I look around the
room here almost everybody on their
professional journey is potentially in a
different place some people want to grow
their business 5x for this flip other
people want to maximize margin for the
next couple of years because they want
to take cash on the table so the
question I would ask is wherever I was
in the life cycle right of my career you
know to me the thing I would ask me
probably
based on where I'm at or what is the
most universal thing that I think could
bring value here is
which platforms and what tactics today
have the potential to reach the most
audience to do business the answer to
that is I believe that as we sit here
today the two platforms that can lead to
the most business are Facebook and
Linkedin for this audience I think
Facebook is incredibly powerful still
and especially for the demo that is
buying a lot of things that we're
talking about here if you're perfect or
really good at ads and pictures and
videos on Facebook more than Instagram
and know how to run ads I think that
will lead to the most sales
LinkedIn I think most people here are
wildly misunderstanding we still think
of it as like a recruiting tool or where
you do your resume but the way the
LinkedIn feed is working is working like
Facebook and you can Target people who
are CFOs a Fortune 500 companies and I
can give you the preview those are high
net worth individuals they get paid a
lot of money to do what they do you
could also make rep references to being
in corporate so you can make your
content very targeted to your media
spend in LinkedIn so that would be the
question and the answer appreciate it
appreciate it
hey Connor it's good to see you nice to
see you
um so we're in the plumbing industry yes
and our biggest thing is face-to-face
sales yes so getting in someone's house
getting dirty getting sweaty or knocking
yeah well no okay not quiet so if they
reach out to us we go to the property
and then we develop a relationship right
where do you see AI interfering with
that nowhere nowhere I see AI enhancing
that by being able to look at how Connor
how do you spend your money now to get
the lead
Direct Mail outdoor Facebook Google what
how do you spend money Facebook Google
Yelp wait you are wasting an ungodly
amount of money in those categories and
of 80 cents on a dollar and 20 cents of
the dollar is making all of it work for
you AI scripts are going to be able to
analyze that and understand which 20
cents are working and making you spend a
dollar on that instead of 20 cents
would you say that plumbing is an
Untouchable industry in regards to AI
because you have to evaluate the problem
and physically yeah yeah I don't think
AI robot I don't think robot plumbers
are coming to take your business exactly
yeah brother I think that about most
things yeah I this is why I want 20
hours of AI even the question to me is
like not silly but like I'm because
think about how you asked the question
and how I changed it yeah you said
interfere and I jumped in naturally and
said enhance
you're thinking [__] Terminator too
yeah
exactly and I'm thinking you're wasting
money on your advertising that AI can
make better got it right so you're going
super macro Fantasyland
and I'm going to I want you to make more
money in 2024 right
appreciate that I appreciate it thank
you you got it
and I just want to add to that question
as somebody who works on AI for plumbing
HVAC industries that is actually one of
the last things that AI can actually
replace fundamentally because as smart
as it is it's only trained on the
internet's data it literally cannot do
this what I'm doing which is gripping an
object with my hand
say
we only won teams and changing the tire
yeah it also isn't here yet serving us
at restaurants like people use Ai and
they expand the definition into robots
right we're talking about scripts that
are analyzing the internet and things of
that nature we're not talking about the
for you by the way back to me being in
heaven in 900 years
robot plumbers are coming
if anyone doesn't think that's true they
just don't know how the world works it
just makes it just might be 212 years
from now my gut's telling me that most
of you don't give a crap about it if
it's like Griffin's not sweating if he
knows it's 212 years from now you know
what I mean but like the world evolves
like think about when the gun was
invented if you're the best swordsman in
the world you're like God damn it
right right like like you know if you if
you own the most horses on Earth at one
point not that long ago and it's our
core transportation and then the car is
invented just to remind everybody a
hundred years ago like you got caught
so Connor's lucky that the robot
plumbers are not coming because it's
2024. but Connor Griffin the fifth who's
a nepo trust fund baby
might get caught
that's how it works
yeah
okay Gary I'm sure you know that there's
been a lot of consolidation in our
industry right so you know nine ten
figure businesses are happening
happening all the time yes
most the top 100 markets are saturated
cost is going through the roof yep so
how does an independent
you know use some guerrilla marketing
tactics through that
great question okay
um
this is why I'm so passionate about what
I do for a living some somebody asked me
the uh many a long time ago like to
really crystallize what I do for a
living and I finally got to the answer
as a matter of fact it's probably going
to be the title of the book I'm working
on right now what I do for a living
which is the answer to your question is
if you're an independent and Lead costs
are going up with the things that we
know about you have to be the best at
day trading attention
so the thing that leads to a lead is
having someone's attention to even know
what you do to then call you to Plum or
whatever else
so back to my point for for a little
while ago about tick tock four years ago
the answer would have been tick tock
it still might be for a lot of people if
they're very extroverted and good at
making videos
you've got to find a place where humans
have attention where nobody else is
doing it at a good enough cost for you
to be able to get what you need out of
it so for example back to the question I
asked Connor for some Independence that
might be door-to-door knocking it might
be long tail Google AdWords it might be
starting a podcast
to build brand awareness so that you can
leverage it
so there are always things and tactics
to be done in contemporary communication
this is still a huge white space to
educate people in this sector I do think
Tick Tock for the most creative and
extroverted operators here is an
opportunity but to find the diamond in a
rough of like a independent plumber or
HVAC person who also has Charisma for
days on video you're talking about a
smaller percentage on the flip side a
lot of people really know their business
back to AI you can work with an AI
component to write a incredible mini
book that can be for free to show people
how to do things at home or how to know
who to hire for HVAC or how to avoid
meeting a plumber because you can five
little things you can learn to do
yourself that you don't need a plumber
for now you're providing value for the
audience which builds trust which makes
me want to work with you even more
because I can't do it because it's the
sixth thing that I can't do so back to
day trading attention pre-roll YouTube
video ads will crush for this industry
but you have to be good at making the
videos and know how to Target it and
what Search terms so having craft in
contemporary marketing is the only way
for an independent because Rising costs
when I started running Google AdWords in
2000 everything was five and ten cents a
click
there are people to your point a lot of
this started the consolidation pe's
interest was there were better operators
in this sector using Google AdWords in
the mid-2000s to build up their business
because they were competing with a lot
of locals as you know who were doing
direct mail and outdoor and Google was
converting it at 30 40 50 cents when
everybody else so there's always an
Arbitrage
the one I gave like for sure LinkedIn is
a massive Arbitrage for the high ticket
items people in the room even for the
day-to-day items so it's about finding
the communication Arbitrage yo Gary
what's up dude it's a pleasure how are
you doing today I'm well good bro so um
first of all it's insane to see in
person I actually don't come to this
country a lot so it's super surreal
thank you normally I'd have a thousand
questions for you but um today I
actually don't have any questions I just
want to say thank you because you've
helped me make millions but at the same
time you've given me perspective to know
that nothing really [__] matters so I
live my life to the best and to the
fullest and you've had a massive
positive play so thank you bro thank you
brother thank you it's very nice
don't know how to follow that it's very
nice thank you brother but jab jab right
hook man dang that changed literally our
business we've been doing these
Community videos where we'll we'll
actually highlight specific people in
the community and I want to know what
what do you do to take it to the next
level because it's funny you said that
the book I just mentioned day trading
attention
was six months ago in my mind called jab
jab jab left hook oh left so I wrote a
book called jab jab jab Right Hook and
the premise was with your social media
content give give give like I was
talking about five ways to not hire a
plumber and on the last on the fifth
post really ask
so find a balance with your content one
of the reasons so many of your companies
are not as effective as they can be in
Social is every post is selfish yep hire
us where the it's at it's all ads but
social it doesn't cost you a lot to make
these ads so why not put out more value
and and then occasionally ask so I
called that jab jab jab right hook
the world that I wrote jab jab jab right
hook for didn't have Tick Tock didn't
have LinkedIn had a different Twitter
had a different Facebook so I feel like
it's time for me to write a new version
so I was I've been writing for the last
year jab jab jab left hook the problem
is I've gotten so nerdy with it it's
like a Bible it's way deeper that it's
like I almost feel weak like I'm almost
bored by my own book because it's really
deep
and so I've decided to Rebrand it to day
trading attention because I think it's a
more overall book than even what I wrote
with jab jab jabri hook so the answer to
your question of like how to follow it
up is for like 14 on Amazon you'll be
able to know all the answers just like
10 years ago I'm almost done with it
they'll be out in the spring appreciate
it and the good news is you know you can
pirate the book on the internet you and
I both know that yeah yeah I don't need
the 14. I get a dollar of the 14 bucks
but like make sure you read it hey man
appreciate it
David
do you know my name I do thank you I was
like how do you know
um so David
um Trio heating and air
you know we've grown as our business
really really fast in the last 18 months
and but yeah we've grown our business
really since in the last 18 months and
one of the things that I'm trying not to
lose sight of is the company culture yes
and I'm I'm really aware you know that
the 50 people that we have right now are
going to build the culture for the next
500 people that are going to come in and
so one of the questions that I wanted to
ask is what are maybe one or two
actionable things that we can do
um you know going back to our businesses
not to lose sight of this and make sure
we're actually you know doing something
to to improve the company culture and if
it is something that you and your
business is you know you have a way to
measure it yeah you know when it's
working I do I do measure it I know how
it's working so David first of all thank
you for asking that question
a company called vaynerx it's a holding
company there's eight companies
vaynermedia being the first and the
biggest I have 2 000 employees globally
when I hear someone come up here and
talk about culture at 50 employees it
motivates me to no end because I'm happy
for you because you're a young dude and
you're and the first hundred dictate
everything
I do have a way to measure culture it's
called retention
how long do people stay at your company
right in my industry advertising
agencies it's like two and a half years
average and we're like at eight and a
half years average and we're only 14
years old so we haven't even had that
much time to have that kind of average
so I know we're winning
which is a which especially with if you
had hyper growth in 18 months
50 feels like a lot how old's the
company
um two years right so 50 feels like a
lot a lot because two seconds ago you
were six and nine and thirteen but at 50
and this is super important at 50 the
biggest mistake people do is they don't
spend one-on-one time with the 50.
the number one way to build a great
culture is to spend one-on-one time with
your employees and here's a key part of
the sentence make them feel safe
tell you the truth of what's going well
and what's not and for you to figure out
what makes them tick I have employees
that are tick on job title because
they're insecure and they want to be a
VP
I've got people that their core and only
motivation is money very common we we
all know that some is work-life balance
some as most are a mix of all three with
different percentages in different way
and I can look at an org chart right now
with you if we flew back together and I
put 2 000 faces and names on a screen
you would hit the ground in shock how
many I could speak to in detail of what
makes them tick on those three
categories right and I'm at 2 400 in
Asia so you can imagine how good I feel
for you I'm like bro it's only 50. spend
the rest of this year and it's be here's
how and I want everybody to hear this
everybody here me included who's
obsessed with what I'm about to say
everyone here wastes multiple hours
every day on dumb [__]
all of us and I'm down to like 53
meetings at 15 minutes of pop and I'm
like talk to my admins I'm like in 2024
we got to go to seven minute meetings
the amount of one-hour meetings this
series of a group is having that are
actually 30 minute meetings and you're
just filling it in
with small talk and like dragging it out
and pontificating at the end is profound
if you at your level analyze your
one-hour meetings make a bunch of them
30. you've just created two 15-minute
slots to check in and shoot the [__] and
really get to know those 50. at night
you take four real winners of you know
who the 16 of those 50 are and you take
six of them for dinner you just start
really committing like a parent to time
with those 50 that tactic time
allocation to make them feel safe to
tell the truth you stink at this they
don't have to be right you just want to
make them feel safe to tell you the
truth of what their Ambitions are what
makes them ticked you have to be
prepared for that to change a 25 year
old might want money but at 32 seven
years from now they might want work life
balance because they just had their
first child so that's the framework you
need to create
amazing amazing
guys we have 10 more minutes for
questions so if you want to ask your
question make sure you get up in there
because we only have like 10 minutes you
will be stuck what happens
I also didn't want to get out of bed is
my bills somehow managed to lose I went
to your jets tough morning thank you for
making me tiny bit feel better
terrible day yeah uh
unlike Josh Allen I'm gonna pull an
audible on my question here uh so I
don't know if you heard of Selena Barnes
by chance of course I live in New Jersey
in New York my whole life sure so well
so they're from Buffalo that's my uncle
celino amazing uh we are we're really
well known in Buffalo and I think a lot
has to do with that
um we are planning to to go East
throughout the state
um do you think from a brand perspective
that that there's an advantage there of
course how much well there's awareness
advantages right there's an awareness
like when I hear Selena burns like I
know what that is that's huge that's
gonna make me click on an ad or convert
at a higher ratio that's why you build
Brands so I think it could be quite
significant but
at some level that doesn't even matter
that's like you know what that's like
I'm gonna give you a good analogy using
sports that I think will resonate with a
lot of people that's like being born
with athletic ability hand-eye
coordination athleticism size and speed
need
most of those people never are good at
sports so like you've got an advantage
but you're still gonna have to execute
you're just gonna get more out of your
work because there's a brand you're
going to extract more value than a lot
of us that have to start from a zero
brand okay you understand you're still
gonna have to outflank everybody on
whatever you do you're gonna have the
billboard buying the billboard creative
the Remnant TV spot the actual 30 second
video buying Google AdWords better but
also the copy underneath the headline
it's not only buying the attention
properly it's filling it with the right
creative to get people compelled to buy
the stuff we all want to sell you're
just going to convert better than us
because the brand is known if you're me
would you leverage that with pi with
what my friend going private Equity is
this something I should consider
leveraging yeah I mean look at all again
this goes back to an earlier question of
like
private Equity you know VCS
uh debt credit lines any financial
instruments for all of us has to be
predicated on where we're at
what scares me about that question is
I don't think there's any right answer I
think you have to have a right answer
for yourself I think too many people
sell their businesses too early I think
too many people raise Capital too early
I think too many people that are old
school don't leverage Capital early
enough I mean I can show you 47
different versions of this I think you
got to know yourself and where you're at
it depends on your patience I mean I
thought I was gonna I I as I sit here
today think I'm going to buy the New
York Jets they're seven billion dollars
34 years old I was still working my
dad's liquor store making ninety
thousand dollars a year one could call
me delusional easily I would respect
that but I knew what I was doing I knew
that I wanted to give back to my parents
I knew that I was honing my skills and I
knew how I was going to play out or at
least I thought at the time my late 30s
40s 50s 60s and 70s and then make a run
at it in my 80s
in my mid-40s starting to get to my late
40s I'm on track but when I started
vaynermedia which again now is a 400
million dollar a year business that I
started from scratch I was already known
a little bit because of my Twitter and
because of my wine stuff I could have
raised Capital but I did it instead I
was willing to eat crap and work out of
a conference room of another company
because I didn't want to I didn't need
to prove to anybody I had my own office
and that allowed me to keep the equity
in my company instead of giving some of
it up I didn't need a fancy chair I
didn't need to fly first class I ate
[__] for four years to keep my Equity
guess what that was a really good idea I
don't know you well enough to know which
way you should go so I think that's why
that's a tough question awesome thank
you and we have time for like two more
questions so two more questions
you guys like the eating [__] one huh
Sean yes thank you for being here Gary
this is great thank you appreciate it I
have a quick tactical question yes for
this industry yes for posting on social
platforms yes how would you think about
The Balancing Act between frequency and
quality I don't think quantity is at the
direct conflict of quality okay and I
love you for asking this question
because it is probably
the biggest thing that I've advocated it
for that has been confusing to a lot of
marketing people because we all default
into that
right uh
here is good at cooking raise your hand
great
my intuition is that the people that
just raised their hands if they were
required to make 53 meals this week that
all of them would be better than my one
meal
because they have talent and practice
and so they can do it so what's
happening is we 've demonized quantity
sometimes to Quality because it's a
saying in our minds but it's incredibly
not true in Social I put out
36 pieces of content a day
across seven different platforms now for
the first seven years of my career
making content I did all of it myself
today on my personal brand I have 20
full-time employees doing that
right but I can tell you right now
especially with AI coming I could put
out a thousand pieces of content right
now that's all I can afford to do
but in the world that we live in
dizziness people not seeing most things
you're not flooding anyone most of the
content's not being seen
by your target so the way I think about
it is as much as you can afford but
actually knowing what good is right so
getting good at the craft of the written
words of the audio of the video of the
pictures got it thank you you're welcome
thank you sir final question so make it
good I was thinking too okay
I won't be long-winded bed my mine's
gonna be oh that was loud uh mine's
gonna be real quick my friend's gonna be
Uncle Ben's you can call me that too
um I just want to say thank you
um I'm somebody who's surrounded with a
lot of people who are just phenomenally
amazing at what they do and uh just blow
to the park consistently and
there's been a lot of times where I felt
like I don't live up to that or I'm not
where I should be or whatever and
there's been so many days where I felt
like I couldn't even get out of bed and
your videos were the thing that really
helped me just feel like I'm exactly
where I need to be and I'm doing what I
need to do and I just you know want to
say I'm I'm forever grateful to you for
that like thank you
I also have something for you thank you
thank you so much I'm very humbled
[Applause]
so Gary I want to kind of bring this all
together please for everybody here today
bring it home Brian
2011 you and I spoke in Oslo at goldthag
and with our friends Chris Brogan Marie
Smith and all that yes and one of the
things you stressed there was about
scaling caring yes scaling the
unscalable and scary no caring caring
for people right like we just said to
that gentlemen and here's the main point
you were saying that a dozen years ago
and most people didn't act on it yes
we've got about 150 people here who
heard you tonight yes
tell them specifically some of the
things you would do today with AI
scale that caring for them thank you
Brad
look I think you all heard me talking
about what I would do internally with 50
employees
I'll give you one back to scaling caring
thank you brother at the time what
Brian's referencing was a book I wrote
is it's called the thank you economy and
it talks about scaling caring and
scaling unscalable things so I'll give
you an example
everybody here can decide after they
hear what I'm about to say do the
following when you go home
start the process of reaching out to
Prior customers
people that have already paid you for
the thing
and call email or text likely email in
order email call text is my gut based on
prior customers
and literally reach out to them and
thank them for working with you in the
past and check in to see how it's been
going
when I say the intent of that is just
that
because humans are animals and we can
sense things and if you go into the
intent of just doing that just for the
sake of saying thank you caring and hope
everything's going well
remarkable things are gonna happen one
you are gonna feel good
this goes back to your day and cut out
an hour and a half of dumb things spend
an hour internally and maybe spend 30
minutes on scaling caring two when you
hang up or when it's obvious that the
intent of your Outreach was just to
check in that person on the other side
is going to be so confused
because it's such a rare Act
that consciously or subconsciously they
will recommend you to a friend or
relative in the next year because it is
a unfortunately rare act to just do
something that nice without any strings
attached
I couldn't recommend it enough and
because even without AI most of you have
that data in a computer somewhere it is
absolutely something you could access
and I think it has a profound impact and
and again especially for the people here
that don't know me in any shape or form
for us to take seven or eight questions
and for two of them to be young men who
just wanted to come up here and say
thank you nothing else
that's all it was you saw it I saw it
I'm very humbled
that's because
tenth of 90 of the content I put out in
the world is to just leave a positive
mark on the world the way my parents
left the positive mark on me and ten
percent of it is by my dad's wine check
out my agency
and and I think there's something there
there and I will continue to scream it
from the top of my Mountains for the
rest of my career and I really
appreciate being with all of you this
afternoon thank you Gary everybody give
it up for Gary man that was awesome
thank you thank you so much thank you
[Music]
this way